well I think there's a public opinion
that if you are in front of the camera
that somehow the public almost owns a
part of your shortness in terms of they
feel that it's their right to know about
your personal life and comment about it
on you too yeah yeah yeah what's your
take on that because they can be very
hurtful things that people say and and
and it's almost as if they treat the
celebrity as of that real everybody's
different you know some people are
comfortable sharing their lives others
aren't um look at something like when is
Paltrow you can go in an interview with
Gwyneth Paltrow and talk to her about
what ever you want about being a mom you
can talk to her about her relationship
you talk to her about who you know she
has a lifestyle website goop that speaks
to lifestyle so she's clearly into
workout routines and what your diet is
and being a mom and Heather always kind
of stuff then somebody else like
Penelope Cruz is very guarded and you
don't mention her personal life with her
she's not gonna give you a good answer
she draws that line and she's worked
really hard at that everybody's
different you're right that we as
moviegoers and and the public feel a
sense of ownership sometimes over the
people in front of the camera I feel
like when it comes to musicians that
line is less simply because that you
would think that they're putting their
emotions and their life and their
feelings into their work so you can talk
about it while actors kind of keep it
separate you know that if you are
married and have a kid and have a life
at home that's different than if you're
on-screen playing a character they're
different people and when you're a
musician I feel like you're giving
yourself into your work reality stars
all bets are off you can ask whatever
the you want cuz if someone's gonna
follow you around with a camera all day
like I'm gonna ask you whatever I want I
don't care you know I always loved that
when you would go and interview like
Jessica Simpson and she's like well I
don't talk about my private life but
i'll point invite some cameras with me
in the bathroom you don't even so that
if you're on a reality show that it's
all bets are off to me but when it yeah
when it comes to movie stars I look at
it like if it's something that's
celebratory in somebody's life it's
usually more interesting and it's okay
to talk
out if service Lee adopted a baby
congratulations your mom now that's
awesome you know but if you're something
that's a little bit more private if
somebody broke up or somebody's and some
sense of this substance abuse problems
that has nothing to do with promoting a
movie and talking about the film so
unless it's it's a fine line to walk and
it's tough and and everybody handles it
a little differently I think I know I've
been lucky over the years to uh to have
experience now where I kind of know
which people are gonna be more engaged
and talking about that kind of stuff and
just you also want it to be interesting
you know you don't want to just so ask
somebody an insanely personal question
just to get on or get them uncomfortable
you want it to be compelling for your
audience at home so if you know that
your audience is really into this
person's private life and that person's
can give you an interesting answer about
it then then why not oh if it's
intelligent smart I'll I'm down with it
if sometimes when it's invasive and
again treating people like they're not
people then this or that got you
journalism then I don't want any part of
that
you